[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les enfants bonsoir le haut alors
nounours comment va ta dents de sagesse
tu les sorties pas trop je me sens
beaucoup mieux et je suis sort et bien
des envies de voir tes petits amis je
suis sûr qu'ils attendent avec
impatience rougeole qui comprenait nous
aussi on aura te donne ça reste comme on
nous
oui si on est sage bonsoir les gens font
encore mal un paddock est double non
quand on sera grand on aura aussi deux
dents de sagesse violent et qu'est ce
qu'on fera quand on sera grand nous
c'est difficile à dire qu'avez vous
envie de faire moi je serai à jacques
paris alors traversé messieurs dames
c'est à vous et les voitures rouges là
bas n'allez pas si vite sinon je vous
comme une contravention moines hosties
c'est qu'on dirait un gros adamus très
gros
ouah attention je vais vous écrasez vue
offensivement c'est trop pour ce
formidable étais tu sais je serai ainsi
speakerine bonsoir j'ai téléspectateurs
bonsoir mes petits amis
là où rts regrets mais elle n'est pas en
mesure de vous diffuser le programme
prévu parce que nous avons eu un
accident mais tu seras trés jolie
speakerine repreneur l'attend écoutez
votre professeur et prenez votre livre
de langue étrangère elle annonce ou
allah vous on salue la alors et toi nous
qu'est ce que tu feras quand tu seras
grand
je saurai apiculteurs j'aurai beaucoup
ta paye je vendrai du mineur mais le
miel ça fait pas mal aux dents de
sagesse
je vais me rendre compte nous ou que ce
bon ça fait beaucoup de bien
autant de sagesse allons il faut être
raisonnable ou lis les petits
mua
[Musique]
au petit nicolas je suis sûr que tu
feras un très bon professeur mais toi
même nom steve frappy pas un très bon
marchand de miel
pourquoi touboul à ce qu'ils mangent du
gourma gilles aux petits garnements
c'était juste pour le goûter là j'étais
de bonne nuit les petits d'année
n'amorce pas nui nicolas seydoux reste
un problème
bonne nuit les enfants à te voilà
nounours alors tu te sens mieux beaucoup
mieux patron et vous savez je deviens ça
à jeu presque pas manger de mineure
s'est très bien nounours allons donc en
route mon bon pas trop bonne nuit
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]